what's going on everybody welcome to
another Python with flask web
development tutorial in this tutorial
I'm gonna be showing you guys how to
utilize SSL so you can have HTTPS on
your website we're going to be using
let's encrypt for this and this is
totally free and it's actually really
really simple especially with Apache
which is what we're using with flask so
let's go ahead and get started so the
website then I'm going to add HTTPS or
SSL to is cyber IO currently you can you
go there and it's just straight up HTTP
and I think it's really important that
we encrypt this website so let's go
ahead and I'm going to move this aside
and this is the website for let's
encrypt it's just literally let's
encrypt dot org and there's a couple of
ways you can get to the steps that you
need to do but we're just going to go
technology how it works go ahead and
click on that and these are the three
steps that you're going to take that's
those three steps plus one more thing is
really all you need to do but actually
there is one more thing we have to do we
have to kind of prepare ourselves for
this so coming back over here let me
just show you currently let's see if
this is even handled no currently like I
can bring over cyber io but if I go WWC
biryeo
I get the Apache configuration page now
I've shown you guys one way to handle
for this but it turns out there's a
better way to handle for www and every
other kind of sub domain basically so
the first thing that we're going to go
ahead and do is we're going to go do a
nano slash etc' Apache to sites
available available and then our is as
was flask app Kampf
go ahead hit enter there and you'll see
here we've got server name cyber Daioh
and the way we worked around this before
was literally copying all of this
pasting another one and just changing
the server name to cyber Dona wwww cyber
toe anyway but that's not going to work
that's going to make let's encrypt angry
we won't be able to do both names so
instead what we'll do is we have server
name SRO but you can have a server alias
so we'll do server alias and server
alias is going to be server alias will
be WWE cyber I oh and that's really all
you have to change so let's go ahead and
context yes good and then we're going to
service Apache to restart and that may
not that should happen pretty quick
actually this should be done yeah so now
WWII works of course if you don't--if
like WWE do doesn't point to anything
ie if you go to your your DNS record and
you don't have a cname for www that's
not going to work anyways but this is
assuming you added a cname for www ok so
moving this over what we're going to do
now is we're going to do the let's
encrypt where did I stuff let's encrypt
I have too many monitors ok so these are
the three steps you want to take
currently we're in the root user
directory probably don't want to stuff
it there so we're going to change
directory into var actually let's change
directory this will just put it back in
root let's see V back to this and then
let's encrypt we'll put it here that
doesn't exist so it's a make der let's
encrypt CD let's encrypt great so now
we're going to run these three
statements now you might not have jit so
you want to make sure that you have it
so just do apt-get install get yes great
once we have that I'm just going to be
copy
paste that's done the next one is to
just CD into let's encrypt hopefully
that double name won't get us in trouble
and then we're going to run this Auto
let's encrypt Auto help okay and then
whenever this is done we'll be ready to
actually add the SSL certificate and
this parts actually really easy it's a
little harder if you have a different
server back-end but Apache is just like
all automated here so waiting on this so
it's taking forever so how's the weather
this picture up
I like that comic okay I don't have to
pause this everyone else is probably
having to wait this long but this is
hanging a long time
I guess I'll pause okay it's done and
actually pretty much finished as soon as
I hit pause as as it would be so anyway
hopefully it didn't take that long for
you but I wanted to polish this in case
it was going really quick and you guys
are just waiting on me
so now what we're going to do is is
period forward slash let's encrypt let's
encrypt and then - Auto no space there -
- Apache - Dee and then this is your
dash D for domain and then you've one of
the domains is going to be cyber IO
and then dash D again the other domain
is going to WW cyber IO everything looks
good we'll go ahead and hit enter here
and this process can sometimes take a
little bit - but basically what's going
to do ok first ask for your email
address this is kind of silly I don't
know why they I wish it was optional if
you skip it you can skip it
and it just kind of yells at you a
little bit but if you ever like lost
anything you would just regenerate a key
like it's so simple to regenerate the
key so I'm pretty sure I would just do
that so anyway I'll read the terms and
all that blah blah blah blah hit agree
this might take a second again normally
it's even faster than this I'm surprised
it's taking as long as it's taking I saw
an error I don't know why I did that but
anyway you can either choose to allow
people to have HTT to like access via
HTTP or you can choose the secure which
basically forces it'll redirect all all
requests to be over HTTPS so I'm going
to go ahead and hit OK here and
congratulations is done you can test
your configuration by going to either of
these examples because those are the
both domains that we did but I'm not
really going to worry about that and
then when you're all done you can come
over and just literally refresh and boom
you now have HTTPS and then we can also
go to the regular version and again
that's HTTP as well so now you have
HTTPS it was totally free and it was
very very fast so that's pretty cool if
you're like me I was like super excited
when when it was like that simple so if
you're using nginx I have a version 4
for that as well so a little more
in-depth it's like a few extra steps but
it's really not that bad so I'm moving
this over one thing I'll just draw your
attention to is normally getting s first
of all getting an SSL certificate is a
pain in the butt getting it all
installed and setup pain in the butt
everything is just so difficult but this
was just
Sooey super easy so normally it can also
costs a lot of money so one thing that
be nice if you have the money to spare
go to let's encrypt org slash donate
give them like five bucks or something
and that'll go a long way because that
was just that's crazy easy so anyway a
couple things to note these certificates
are 90 days so you need to re-up the
certificate once every 90 days
you you you can do it like once a day I
mean you might actually probably run out
then but like once a month or once every
you can set an alert somewhere just to
do it literally all you need to do to re
do the certificate is literally that
same thing we just did you just run this
command and it'll reissue you a
certificate and that's that's it's so
simple I think it's awesome couple
things to note if you have any links on
your website obviously for us we
generated our links via the generally a
variable but if you have any links in
your you're linking today CH TTP address
you will break this connection it'll be
like a so it'll be like black and white
rather than green that's what's
happening you've got some insecure
elements on the page one thing you can
do is every time you link to something
rather than linking to HTTP colon slash
slash or HTTP colon slash slash you link
to simply slash slash in the URL and all
that and that will work both with HTTP
or HTTPS but if you use the static
variables and stuff especially for
elements within your website that's
already handled for on the back end
anyway
that's all if you have questions
comments concerns something didn't work
out for you or whatever let me know
leave your questions comments below
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support subscriptions
and it till next time